all right it's time let's get into this
week's hatred mail so what if the
president's been accused of sexual
harassment 15 times or that he paid hush
money to a porn star at least he never
wore a tan suit patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom so last week
hatred mail coined a new phrase that I
really like which is ad hominem instead
of ad hominem it's an ad hominem this
week there's another new phrase coined
by hatred mail but it makes no sense the
phrase is anti facets it's opportune and
if that doesn't make any sense to you it
certainly doesn't make any sense to me
let's take a listen David Pakman I had
sex with your wife you cook I am
clicking not interested in the David
Pakman show don't want to listen to this
PC vindictive ex show anymore
a news radio station David Pakman and a
wife whose bidders ass is also clearly
greedy didn't you have concerns David
hmm
Antipas eat eat supper tuned exactly
right anti facets it's off poor toon and
a good its opportune to you Pat it's
good to have you back on the program is
yeah is there like a prescription
medication name I'd have no idea what
that is I I think I actually saw a
commercial for talking to your doctor
about anti facets it's opportune on late
late-night television last night here's
one phrase that I know the meaning of
precisely and it's hey tree at forty
that's the coupon code that'll save you
forty percent off of a david pakman show
membership and every time you sign up
for membership using the coupon code hey
tree at forty thirteen hey tree it's
shed it's here and I think that that's
something we can all be very very glad
about